This video is brought to you by keeps.
Fast. He may tease maroon, see dog Jared, here to
talk about a 2019 films.
So unpredictable that the phrase jaw dropping feels like an absurd
understatement. The lighthouse,
whenever a movie leaves me feeling that weird cocktail of impressed all and
confusion I have to wonder,
is this film too smart or is it just pretending to be let's investigate in this
wisecrack condition on the lighthouse, deep or dumb, and of course,
spoilers ahead. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to keeps a lot of, you know, how much I like my hair.
It's part of my identity. So I'm scared out of my mind about losing it.
And from what I've learned, prevention is the key.
If you've noticed your hair thinning and want to keep yourself from going bald,
you've probably already invested in prevention techniques,
but staying out of the sun or throwing away all your hats won't solve the
problem because genetics are the main cause of male pattern.
Baldness keeps is a prevention tool you can use to save your hair.
Keeps offers FDA approved treatments to combat the symptoms of hair loss with
keeps you meet with the doctor online,
or do your prescription or over the counter medication and get everything
delivered right to your door with keeps some men even experienced hair regrowth.
If you're noticing hair loss, do something about it. And try keeps today,
click the link in the description or go to keeps.com/wisecrack.
And you can save 50% off your first order. And now back to the show, all right,
guys, let's do a quick recap. Lighthouse spotlights, no pun intended.
The relationship between seasoned lighthouse keeper old played by Willem Defoe
and his reluctant mentee young played by that vampire guy.
Who's arguably the best young actor of the moment. Anyway, old is gassy
and gas lady potentially screwing with young, for his own amusement,
putting him through punishing physical labor,
and constantly trying to get him wasted.
To leave and toast unfinished, right?
While also refusing to let young look at his precious lantern the day before
they're supposed to finally leave. Everything goes buck wild,
young kills the out of a seagull causing a gnarly storm to brew.
And then it's like, man, do I need a drink?
The men bond open up about their past and even sing fun sailor songs.
[Inaudible].
When the ferry fails to pick them up things to generate fast young,
who we've learned, killed his former boss and assumed his identity.
I just stood there. It was all just, just stood.
Watched him get swallowed by them. Logs.
Loses all this and beats up old, eventually killing him,
but not before pausing to hallucinate him as his dead boss,
a mermaid and a squid creature. Then young finally gets to see the light,
which is a beautiful serene experience.
[Inaudible].
Kidding. It just about kills him.
And we end on an unutilized friendly shot at him,
lying naked on a Rockwell birds Peck at his innards,
which we have thoughtfully concealed with Nick cage gifts. Okay.
So what the name of Poseidon just went down the way we see it.
There are countless possible ways to glean meaning from this film.
So we're going to focus on three aesthetics,
psychosexual dynamics and mythology. Let's start with aesthetics.
According to the film cinematographer,
Jaron [inaudible] Edgar said that atmosphere comes first and then the rest comes
out of that. And boy, this film's got atmosphere for days.
It feels out of a different non-specific time with an old fashioned boxy,
one point 19 to one aspect ratio that visually smushes the two men together and
makes us increasingly claustrophobic.
They also mimic the look of ortho chromatic film,
which dates back to the early days of photography and was particularly used for
portraits fittingly.
The first frontal view of young and old is presented almost as if they're posing
for an old fashioned portrait. As they gaze at the camera unnaturally,
still ortho chromatic, film filters out red light,
giving the sky a washed out look and people's faces a darker,
more textured complexion. It's evocative and surreal.
It makes the actors look weathered as hell because they were using old lenses
and an old style of film.
Everything about the production process had to be super meticulous.
The ortho chromatic look requires a ton of light in the film set was so bright
to that.
Apparently some film crew members wore sunglasses even during nighttime scenes,
which is honestly just called style.
There's some intimation throughout that light is dangerous.
The interior shots grow steadily brighter as old learns more about young shady
pass. And of course the lighthouse is extreme.
Brightness seems to basically kill young at the end, but it's not totally clear.
Now this film probably has the coolest aesthetics of 2019 full stop,
but try as we might, we couldn't unearth any overarching meaning behind them.
So for this one,
we're going to say atmospheric has hell but not quite deep though.
Definitely let us know if we're missing something.
Let's move on to part two sexuality, AKA your high school, gym teachers,
second expertise.
Don't have sex cause you will get pregnant and die.
From phallic lighthouses to vaginal keyholes sex is front and center,
which is fitting for a movie that features dudes jerking their lighthouses about
every five minutes. It's most obvious in the tensions between young and old,
who like your boomer parents vacillate between yelling at each other and
embarrassingly slow dancing.
The queerish subtexts are pretty clear and Eggers along with actors,
Robert Pattinson and Willem Defoe told the Huffington post that this was
intentional. The whole thing is about power dynamics.
So it is about Willem pushing, pushing, pushing, pushing, pushing,
and there's pent up anger and pent up erotic energy and pent up smells.
Where is that breaking point? Indeed,
the struggle for power is central to the plot. Old claims,
absolute control telling young to throw the rule book way because he's the King
of this.
Castle manuals. My longest book on this rock. Yeah.
Alternates between telling young to do the hardest possible chores and yelling
at him for having supposedly done them wrong.
Even dangles him from a rope just to be a jerk.
These dynamics come to fruition in a bizarre mirror image.
When young takes old for a walk like he's a dog and an image that feels straight
out of a kink handbook here, a young is expressing the dehumanization.
He felt when old regularly called him a dog.
Small dog smell.
And reclaiming his power taken on its own old behavior is just dickish put in
the context of physical and emotional relationships with young though,
it becomes pretty clearly erotic as if to bring the point home Eggers of Oaks.
The work of Sasha Snyder,
a late 19th century painter who had to flee Germany because of his sexuality.
And one of the film's most striking moments, Eggers recreates,
this Schneider painting called hypnosis,
which depicts one man's face shining light onto the face of a younger man as if
revealing some frightening and seductive truth is Eggers.
Perhaps suggesting that interacting with old reveal, some frightening,
but seductive truth about young, maybe a new gradation of his sexuality.
Now we're not saying that they're gay and neither is Eggers.
It's hardly that simple, regardless of which way they typically swing.
They enter into a tacitly erotic relationship out of loneliness or genuine
sexual attraction.
They're each fulfilling a need of the other old gets to feel in control.
Despite living in a world, dictated by the uncontrollable forces of the sea.
And as for young Robert Pattinson explained to his character and a lot of ways
he sort of wants a daddy and boy, does he get one?
The pure erotic fascination has given plenty of time to brew on screen.
There's lots of secretly watching one another from a distance and old even calls
young DSM picture. There's also moments of reprieve,
softer images of their relationship.
Like when they sit peacefully by the fire as old engages in your traditionally
domestic hobby of knitting, however,
they still manage to make even peaceful feminized tasks,
impetus for more hyper-masculine aggression, not incidentally,
their most tumultuous fight erupts over whether or not young likes olds cooking.
I seen it. You're fun to me, loves them.
Rather than expressing his pain and vulnerability.
Something he might see as overly feminine,
old immediately turns to his most wildly violent impulses,
literally calling on Triton to, uh.
Joe G and gorging your organs stay, eat turned blue,
and don't take with bill and Brian and can stream no.
Yeah. That old sick Seadog monologue brings us to another point.
The films treatment of the nebulous line between sex and death take this
climactic moment. When young finally sees the light.
[Inaudible].
What is he experiencing?
Just pain or a weird pleasure in pain that strange duality has fascinated
many thinkers, including George [inaudible], whose book Aero, autism, death,
and sensuality outlines the odd relationship between these two aspects of human
experience. According to [inaudible],
we are from the very beginning individuals existing in a state of discontinuity
from those around us, that is a state of isolation and loneliness.
Death jerks us out of a tenacious obsession with the lastingness of our
discontinuous being that is,
it literally destroys our sense of a singular separate self in doing so.
It actually affirms our continuity of being or as literary scholar Nadella two
puts it in depth.
We go from separate beings to a common ontological ground of being
because we both desire that continuity and fear are inevitable death.
We search for continuity elsewhere, specifically in eroticism as Baton put it.
The whole business of eroticism is to destroy the self-contained character of
the participators as they are in their normal lives.
I eat to destroy our discontinuity by uniting intimately with another in this
way, eroticism is a psychological quest,
not alien to debt because both were about recovering our lost continuity
overcoming our profound sense of separation.
This idea feels very present in the lighthouse.
Most apparently when young finally sees the alluring lantern,
which has already been thoroughly sexualized,
the moment feels in line with [inaudible] definition of the sacred,
in that it seems to cause young,
both divine ecstasy and extreme horror of phenomenon.
We also see in Young's earlier masturbatory adventure in the shed,
which ends with him on his knees in pain. Now,
according to [inaudible] the experience of the erotic that is the tearing down
of your usual self containment is a rupture. His erotic system is often violent.
The link between violence and erotics manifest in the many brawls between young
and old,
when they can be just as easily about to make love as they are about to kill one
another. But the dichotomy is most glaringly obvious in the moment,
right after the two almost kiss. When instead of locking lips,
they lock fists right here.
We have a textbook example of two dudes not being able to distinguish between
love and violence fittingly for this moment. But tile pine,
that extreme seductiveness is at the boundary of horror,
which we certainly see in Young's frightened reaction to old's embrace and the
lighthouse. There's a poorest relationship between sex and death,
love and violence, some literal and some symbolic more subtly.
There's the ongoing motif of a post-coital cigarette first scene when young
lights up after jerking into his favorite half woman, half fish,
of course the Postbank SIG is coily being repurposed for both sexual and violent
encounters. Young describes wanting a cigarette after watching,
letting and or causing his boss to die.
I could think when he was done was I,
I could use me as smoke.
And he also lights up after killing old.
What's more the original script even has him doing the same thing after killing
the seagull underscoring, Eggers intentions,
similarly old poles up his suspenders after his rendezvous with a lamp,
a moment the script describes as,
as if getting dressed after a night with a woman echoing this moment,
young pulls up his suspenders after beating old to a pulp,
as of getting dressed after sex, sex death.
What's the difference all in all the unique take on sexuality and the
interesting treatment of the line between sex and death love and violence feels
pretty deep to us. Let's conclude by looking at mythology,
the lighthouse evokes parallels to numerous myths,
fables and folklores drawn from a myriad of seafaring cultures. For example,
the idea that seagulls contain the souls of dead sailors is a real maritime
myth,
which may have brought about the historical superstition that killing a seabird
is bad luck. This effect was most famously described in the 1798 poem.
The rhyme of ancient Mariner,
which shows a sailor doom has shipped by killing an albatross as punishment.
He is forced to wear the dead bird around his neck.
Like an especially unattractive scarf.
Young is regularly tormented by a hostile one eyed seagull upon learning that
the Virtus team, Jacob, he beats it to death in a violent rage.
This appears to seal his fate as the wind suddenly changed direction and a storm
ensues, but there's more one eyed imagery to hunt your dreams.
When young inquires about the previous junior Wiki old replies that he went mad
and died.
The second died
went to Maddie did.
Later on young seems to hallucinate the severed head of a man with one eye
there's was ones between the one I had former keeper.
And the one I'd seal is undeniable.
So what does it mean was the previous keeper attempting to warn young about the
malevolence of the lighthouse?
Possibly then there's the mermaid who appears both as a figurine and an actual
part lady part fish with,
and this is according to Eggers of vagina modeled after that of a sharks equal
parts of beautiful and terrifying.
The mermaid has symbolized erotic danger everywhere from medieval churches to
Greek mythology or sirens learned many,
a horny sailor who is due frequently in such tales,
mermaids pull their sailor lovers under water,
leading to some pretty awkward one nightstands such a moment happens during
Young's masturbatory fantasy and or nervous breakdown in this way.
The mermaid helps solidify this. After mentioned the link between sex and death,
then there's the other assorted oceanic imagery,
which tends to revolve around old.
This is most notable during the men's deadly fight in which old seems to
spontaneously sprout squid tentacles before also fading into a barnacle covered
version of himself. That salary honestly just recalls this guy. Oh,
and he also fades into the mermaid what's going on here is old simply emblematic
of all Silor representing the way some men subsume their lives and identities to
the ocean waves and thus get swallowed up in all its mysteries.
Maybe we honestly don't know. And then of course,
there's the illusion to the Greek myth of Prometheus's the Titan who was
punished by Zeus for stealing the secret of fire and bestowing it up to humanity
in this myth,
fire symbolizes humanity's curiosity for knowledge and triumph over nature.
The titular lighthouse exists in the film as a font of forbidden knowledge and
the object of Young's obsession. And you know, it's also literally a flame.
Now the gods punished Promethease for being a bad boy by chaining him to a rock
for all eternity to have his liver eaten by an Eagle every single day,
only to regenerate at night in the final scene of the film.
We see Young's liver being picked upon by a one eyed Siegel,
Allah Prometheus's the gods also punished manity by giving it its first woman
Pandora described in Greek poetry as a beautiful evil through Pandora and her
dang box.
All the evils in the world are released the theme of femininity and beauty as
beguiling and dangerous is Telegraph throughout via the mermaid as well as the
assorted attribution of feminine traits and duties to both old and young is
young being punished for stealing the fire of the lighthouse is that the result
of his fear of femininity and his latent desires, to be honest,
we're not totally sure. And we're totally sure if it's deep. Okay.
So this is honestly been one of the harder films we've ever analyzed.
And we think we know why Eggerss himself has said that he wanted to make the
movie in conclusive. He wanted to raise more questions than answers.
[Inaudible].
To spend hours on Reddit,
trying to understand the significance of the lobster trap.
This is a pretty cool approach that not many directors are brave enough to take
less. They be labeled pretentious. We truly applaud it.
The only downside is that such an approach can result in the film,
not articulating any clear meaning the lighthouse is many things at once.
A love story, a hate story, a story of madness and obsession.
But despite all these gradations,
no interpretation fully makes it clear statement.
The movie lacks a thesis and it does so intentionally as a result,
we're a little dumbfounded. It's clearly not superficial,
but can you be deep if you're not fully articulating a message we're genuinely
not sure.
So we're going to split the difference and say quite possibly deep and quite
certainly not dumb.
But what do you think wisecrack as Robert Eggers broken deeper, dumb,
or is there another interpretation? We like a one eyed Siegel simply cannot see,
let us know what you think in the comments.
Thanks to all our dope patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast hit
that subscribe button. Like it's an angry old sailor.
Who's making you shovel call and as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].